-You look fantastic.
Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-Can I just see the bling?
-Oh, the "blanga, blang."
-Wow, wow, wee, whoa.
Look at that right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations!
-Thank you!
-How long have you been engaged?
-"It's been 84 years."
-"84 years."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah. How long?
-For a little over
three years now.
-No way.
-Yeah.
-To my man, to -- to Wells.
-Yeah, to Wells.
-Wells, I love him.
-You love Wells!
-I really do.
-Who doesn't love Wells?
-I'm a big fan.
-[ Laughs ]
-But how did he do it?
-So, we went on vacation.
We went to Fiji.
-Ooh!
-2019, very excited.
Our first time.
And he had planned this.
The -- the property
that we were staying at
had this little private island.
So, we went over there,
and I was like,
"Oh, this is happening.
He's proposing."
'Cause, you know, witch stuff,
you just know.
And so --
-Witch stuff.
-Witch stuff, you know.
-Yeah, you just felt the vibe.
You go,
"We're on a private island.
This got --
it better happen now."
-I mean, it doesn't really
have to take witch stuff
to know private island...
I've been with this guy
for a while.
It's happening.
-Okay.
-And so, we get off the boat,
we're on the beach.
And he's like, "Let's take
a picture on the drone."
Now, I don't know anything
about technology.
I'm very, very bad with it.
-So he has a drone with him?
-He has a drone with him.
-And so,
he has it up in the sky.
We're, like, choosing, like,
rosé or something like that
for the picture.
And I look down, and I see this
big, like, black box, like,
for the carry-on drone thing --
technology words are hard.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
A drone box.
-A drone box, thank you.
-No, I just made that up.
It's not an official name,
is it?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, drone box.
It's not the name of it.
-It sounds right, though.
-Yeah, so the box
that the drone's in
is on the beach with you, right?
-It's on the beach.
It's right by our feet.
And I was like, "Move the box."
-Yeah, let's get
a good picture here.
-Turns out he had the ring
in the drone box --
thank you for the words --
the entire time.
And that's why...
-That's where it was?
-...we had to Photoshop
all of the pictures
with the box out of it.
[ Laughter ]
-But that's pretty cool, though.
It's like he got out of the box
and gave it to you there.
-Yeah, it was very sweet.
-You have a text message
that you posted...
-Oh.
-...of you guys
when you were dating.
-Yes.
-And I love this.
This is where --
So you were just talking,
and this is a text --
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-And -- and he says, "Wait.
You love bologna, too?"
[ Laughter ]
And you go, "Yeah, I used
to eat bologna on its own,
Oscar Mayer."
And he's like,
"I'm gonna marry you one day,
Sarah Hyland."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And you put, "Hahaha.
You're full of bologna."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And he wasn't.
He wasn't full of bologna.
-He wasn't full of bologna.
-You're engaged!
-I'm engaged!
-I love that.
That's the real deal.
That's love.
-It happened.
I took a screenshot
so just in case he didn't
follow through on that, I could,
you know, have some evidence
for the lawyers.
-We wanted to congratulate you
on hanging in there, too...
-Stop it right now.
-So here's a lifetime supply
of bologna.
-Stop!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Congratulations!
Best of luck!
"Dip it in ranch."
-"Dip it in ranch."
-"Dip it."
-"Dip it.
Just dip it."
-I'm crying.
I'm crying.
-Can we talk about
"Love Island"?
-Yes, please, let's talk about
"Love Island."
-I'm obsessed because right now,
something's happening.
It's real.
It's live.
-Something's happening
right now.
-But they're do -- they're up
to no good right now.
-Someone is crying right now.
Someone's making out right now.
-Someone's making love
right now.
-Ooh!
On the island?
-On Love Island.
-Ooh!
-Yes!
How did you get involved,
and how fun is it,
and how great are these
characters and these people?
-Oh, my gosh, it's so fun.
So they just called me up,
you know, the good ol' Peacock.
-Yeah.
-Called me up and asked me.
And I said, "Yes, thank you
so much, Peacock."
-Yeah.
-I love -- obviously,
love reality dating shows.
-The Peacock.
-I love the Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
"Love Island" --
perfect show for the Peacock.
-Perfect show for the Peacock.
We love it.
-Yeah.
-And the people on it,
we have 10 sexy --
and by sexy, I mean, like,
very, very, very sexy
human beings on this show.
-Really?
-I could not stop staring.
I thought H.R. was
gonna have an issue with me.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, "Wow. That is, yeah."
-I was like, "Oh, no,
maybe Sarah was a bad choice
as a host. She keeps on
staring at the contestants."
-So, they're all
good-looking people.
-They're all very beautiful,
lovely people.
And they do sexy,
naughty challenges.
Very naughty.
-Yes.
-And they're looking for love.
-And the audience decides,
right?
-The audience does.
So, the audience watches along.
We shoot in real time.
We're on Tuesdays
through Sundays.
-Yeah.
-Six nights a week
we are on Peacock.
-Tuesdays through Sundays
on Peacock.
Well, I want
to show everyone a clip.
Here's Sarah Hyland
in "Love Island USA."
Take a look.
-It is time to meet Jesse.
-♪ Watch me,
just watch me now ♪
♪ Oh-oh ♪
-Ooh, cute.
-♪ Watch me, oh-oh ♪
-♪ Just watch me now ♪
-What's up, what's up,
what's up?
-Jesse, hello.
-Hello. Hello.
-Welcome to Love Island!
-Thank you. Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-How you feeling?
-I'm feeling great now.
Wow, wow.
I mean, God bless America.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-That's a good opening line
right there.
Sarah Hyland, congratulations
on the engagement.
-Thank you, bud.
-You're the best, bud.
Check out "Love Island USA"
now on Peacock. Now!